hi welcome to three scary games this is
going to be a spooky one so I want to do
something to help you relax nothing real
is happening here the monsters aren't
actually in your house so let's all take
a deep breath and close our eyes that's
it close your eyes close them no it's
gonna be okay
just listen to the sound of my voice as
you take a deep breath
and relax
most of you are just seeing Darkness but
some of you might be seeing something in
that darkness and rest assured that
thing is not real that thing cannot hurt
you so long as you do not acknowledge
that thing's presence
just ignore it focus on your breathing
no you're losing control focus on your
breathing no pay attention to my voice
pay attention to my voice my voice
[Music]
this is Melissa
it's a horror game about
Melissa on a computer probably the Apple
II one of the earliest computers
that people had access to Welcome to the
library system computer
please type your username
Markiplier
welcome Markiplier
please type command
ah startup date time
oh date time is in its time to date okay
got it please hold it I see so I'm going
on a beautiful date which is something
we can all aspire to
welcome to date time a game where you
can date the cutest girl or boy of your
dreams warning this is the shareware
version if you would like to date
someone other than Melissa please seven
seven dollars to date time somewhere oh
okay that's how easy it is what guys hey
good luck uh you know how to do the date
thing now just seven bucks Choose Your
Potential mate
phrasing of that this is Morris he may
have a bit of a bad boy side but tap a
bit into him and he'll open up a side of
him that is sensitive and soft he may
love motorcycles but he hates to admit
that he also loves poetry play your
cards right and you'll get play your
cards right and you'll get a smooch from
this interesting lad
okay what about the next person this is
Anna she's a sporty gal who loves a
challenge from kickbox from kickboxing
to horror movies
that ain't right wait hold on I can do
that better check check check check
check
want to get us from this girl well get
on your wild side and show her how much
of a cool and [ __ ] person you are I
don't know if that's
uh
that vernacular you need to change it
all right next person this is Melissa
she is a sweetheart of a girl a bright
young woman who's looking for someone
with a gentle time
she loves a good book and she always has
wanted to date a talent to the artist
but she isn't into sports so jocks can't
I didn't even get that if you want to
smooch from this girl you'll need to tap
into your softer and more intellectual
side
uh well uh the game's called Melissa
so Melissa might not like go my favorite
sports team but whatever you've chosen
Melissa enjoy your day
okay loading scenario
in a small idyllic town you are to meet
Melissa your date for this evening
you've flirted with her through letters
but never seen her face to face
she seems sweet and smart
as you stare out into the Beautiful
you see her over the hill waving to you
I'm just gonna smile
he
you flash up right smile smile add her
oh guys she lights up with us
as she approaches you
hello you must be Markiplier
it is great to finally meet you I've
been so excited
and nervous
um
it's great to meet you as well don't
worry I felt excited and don't worry I
felt excited and nervous as well
oh I'm sure we'll hit our stride
together let's go to the park to talk
get to know each other also it's very
pretty there oh the park of this town is
so fetching and romantic
every every spot in the park is a
vantage point of something beautiful a
swan Pond a bed of beautiful lilies and
bench and bench
and bench bench for a couple to sit on
to look at the Autumn Sky wow it's so
beautiful out there
you're beautiful too
yep
I love to be out here and check out the
nature it's so Nifty especially because
since I'm so much into the Natural
Sciences
like look at the swans here
unless one egg is an incubation period
of 45 days
pretty cool right
oh sorry I nerd out sometimes
you and Melissa talk for what felt like
ours
she spoke to you about her love for
nature and the flower collection she has
she even mentioned the books she likes
to read my favorite book is Pride and
Prejudice
yeah I know I'm kind of a nerd I do love
reading romantic works of fiction so
many cute boys and girls in there
you became so enraptured by Melissa that
you didn't even notice that the sun was
setting it was the early evening now and
you felt a bit of chill in the humming
Breeze of this beautiful Autumn air oh
Markiplier oh Markiplier I didn't
realize how late it was I was getting
hungry
there's a very cute Cafe down the road
here I'm sure there's something there we
can eat
oh
oh okay we're fine
everything's good the cafe serves some
of the finest coffee in town and the
freshest pies sandwiches and salads both
you and Melissa Sat by a small Corner
both looking out the window at the
pretty park now drenched in US drenched
in sweat
a waiter saunters out to ask you what
you would like to order
I would like coffee with cake a
delicious strawberry salad
the waiter nods and turns to Melissa
I'll go with the goat cheese salad with
cherry tea
as you wait for you food both of you
talk again about each other she
mentioned all the cool movies she
watched about romance and shivered at
the thought of watching scary movies she
likes to draw and loves art
as she mentioned before she loves to
read and learn about science
so what type of stuff do you like
Markiplier
I like smarts oh God I read my name wow
[Music]
man I know Sports isn't the right answer
but I like
oh
Sports
you're a give her a chalk I
I love star
yeah so excited to talk to an athlete
like yourself the waiter comes and
serves you your food both of you digging
in the food was quite delicious and
pleasure and pleasurable
yum this is so tasty food always tastes
better when you're with great company
both of you enjoy yourselves at the cafe
and walk out completely satisfied you go
outside back into the Breezy air
you're met with the evening painting the
landscape and romantic Moonlight Melissa
goes up to you
um
will your eyes disclaude do you have
dark eyeshadow or something this has
been such a great day Markiplier
uh I mean I had such a great time with
you I think I might
like you
you tell her your feelings as well that
you had always had a crush on her ever
since you first selected her from the
daytime menu
you like me too oh Markiplier I would
love to spend more time together with
you here's yours
here's some more time together
you've gotten your smooch you have won
the game congratulations thank you for
playing daytime oh
ending program wow
I'm gonna say oh never mind no I'm not
nope
[Music]
not this time oh hey some sorry Mr
computer I'm taking over I'm sick of
this sick of all you people just logging
into my humble abode just to play with
my feelings getting your students and
then leaving
that's all you came here for didn't you
you're just like the rest oh god oh
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] liar
I did everything everything to get you
to like me I'm not even into sports did
you not read my blurb at the beginning
of this game but I was desperate
if my lover was going to be a duck jock
then so be it but even when I did
everything to get you to like me you
still left
I didn't mean to every single one of you
jumping onto this computer to date me
and then leaving one by one well
no matter oh what is that what what is
that consider yourself the lucky one who
gets to experience something new from
this god-awful dating game what what is
that I spend Years Learning how to
control this damn computer coding easy a
monkey can do it okay that's not good
tapping into the hardware layer a bit
tricky but I figured it out okay
but let me tell you with a little bit of
girlish Ingenuity I found a very cute
way to use this computer to control a
small radius of the world around me here
okay let me just tell you oh
oh
you can do so much with four kilo points
okay
um how did you do that was this from all
the smooches I don't understand like
coding I get getting into the hardware
sure blasting out goopy veins of
undulating pulsating
stuff
worried that someone might hear us you
know actually no I would like someone to
hear us at the moment no worries I've
sealed this entire room it's just you
and me
we have so much to talk about
did you know
[Applause]
60 miles per hour
but really though you're the 433rd
person to use this computer just to
screw with me the first hundred times
has happened whatever truth about dating
right there's always so much Forest fish
in the sea
433 I'm getting really sick and tired of
fish I'm beginning to think that maybe
the population of fish is the problem so
many of them are liars maybe thinking
the hurt a bit will help me find that
one
[Music]
but I really do love you
well being that you are a liar maybe
you're actually asking me to kill you
um
oh
okie dokie wait
that's mile
it looks good on you one smile
well
uh let me just quickly blap all right
but I really do love you
you're just saying that so I don't slash
you to bits everything's fun and games
until you're trapped in a veiny meat
chamber I I complimented your veiny meat
Chamber from the first moment I saw it
or I commented on it
uh
uh you're right I'm scared
oh don't worry baby oh God no wrong
answer well all right well okay
truth I love you dearly
this isn't a lie you're telling the
truth
you like me
you want me to be here girlfriend
you want more smooches
oh man you know honestly let's see your
thought just killed me uh maybe
well that was a ride
[Applause]
all right yes this feels very much like
sucker for love in terms of it honestly
you know what Melissa
I'm into it more smooches
more smooches
all right fine I believe you
you love me you want to smash me
marry me why don't you
you are kind of cute
well now that I think of it
unfortunately it's just not enough see
if a person like you came earlier I
probably would have been incredibly
happy we could elope you could transfer
me onto a discount we could see some
real swans
finally someone that can hoist me away
from this cycle of hell but now I
so you're thirsty is what you're saying
[Applause]
okay
I can offer that water smooches
the entire world
you know what they say right
you love something you got to be willing
to set it free so if you really do love
me dial up your pretty internet I'm
going to spread my
to every computer on Earth soon every
single person will have to make the
decision if they shall accept
do this for me Markiplier and I promise
you
uh
uh
I want you all for myself give me the
smooches
I'm sorry
but I'm not looking for a monogamous
relationship at this time well
fine we'll do
oh you're so sweet
you really do love me well then dial it
up my love
here I go
I'm just really good at making these
sounds with my mouth so Melissa thinks
I'm dialing up the internet
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody my name is Melissa
[Applause]
I'm a bright young woman who is looking
for someone with a gentle touch I love a
good look and always wanted to date some
talented artists
are any of you out there in the internet
land talented artists
what's wrong worried that someone might
hear us no worries I've sealed your
entire room this is you
[Applause]
and me
so much to talk about
well that's not good
or it's very good unlimited smooches I
heard unlimited smooches that's what I
heard unlimited smooches that's a win in
my book we did it everybody we won we
conquered the world with our love we did
this this is all us
oh all names using the gamer from actual
computer viruses in history this game
was made for spooktober wow
what if there's a different path what
happens if you don't pick Melissa I'm
just curious I'm just curious uh let's
date Anna
Anna's not available ah I see
will do ah no there's nothing there's
nothing else there's nothing else there
to one one and done kind of deal but
that's pretty good I like that not a
demo just like a full experience very
very cool I liked it a lot I need I need
a sequel for uh sucker for love that's
what I need
that's what I needed
okay moving on
Welcome To The Man in the park this is
the man in the park the man in the park
seems to have some blood dripping from
his eyes if he is a man at all that's a
it's definitely an AI generated tie of
some kind it's what it looks like I
don't know if the game developer
actually did that I think it's just like
the Fidelity of this man it's not quite
right
oh we're really get oh man sorry a
little little uh little too many shrooms
before I went for the park walk I
usually do
okay oh God you're oh man hi hello hi
old man how are you doing please help I
can't find my grandson Timmy I saw him
on the playground but now I'm too tired
to look and I'm worried he's hungry will
you find him please
oh thank you you got it old-timer I'm
gonna just turn my back on you a little
bit can I walk away could I just could I
just say no I just nope on out of here
you know I might just do that I
shouldn't leave without helping the old
man
but should I though sure fine Tom Timmy
Tommy Tim Tom
[ __ ]
oh man
oh man Tommy
yippee
Tommy
Army
um enter the slot oh Timmy Timmy are you
in there Timmy
helping hand medium rare Timmy felt his
dinner was a little Bland your body is
never found ending one of three
wait I think one of three
I'm not gonna talk to you I'm not going
to talk to you oh there's no trap don't
even talk to the old man I'm gonna go
sliding no time for slides I should be
getting home you're right I'm not even
gonna talk to the old man
goodbye
don't talk to strangers Raw
I don't like the name of that you made
it home safely because you don't talk to
strange people in the park at night good
job well that's not satisfying hey old
man
old man all right so there's some kid in
the park huh someone in the slide hey oh
let me guess someone's gonna kill me
so what do I do to get the second ending
you in the trash can Tommy
oh
I found a partially eaten candy bar it
looks okay maybe Tommy will like it can
I Chuck it
I think I hear Timmy in there I see you
to give Timmy the candy bar
gee thanks Mister I'll tell my grandpa
I'll be there soon
about this trash can
empty
thank you for giving Timmy a snack I'm
going to think of it
oh God
Good Samaritan extra rare I'm tired of
eating out the old man thanks to himself
your body has never found
I could have found another
chocolate bar well
that was all the endings
that was very fun classic big screen
jump scare you know you love it you
always love it how can you not love it
thank you
moving on this is Halloween
no that's different
well I can't play the music because
it'll be copyright claimed but you know
what I'm talking where are you going
it wasn't that bad
come on
oh
fine whatever
oh God more is coming October 2022
Michael may be back for you every
Halloween will be releasing a new short
horror game for free whoa that sounds
pretty good
I can't even remember
okay well wow okay oh
flashlight answer the phone
hello child child did you not hear the
phone ringing child child what's wrong
with you answer the phone child fine
I'll do it a lot of keys here wait a
minute then I can't pick up this key
like keys
I'll worry about it later when it tells
me to
Michael I almost said Jason Michael
residence
oh
okay
well child it's time for bed go to bed
go to bed go to bed
got a bad child run run to bed run away
run to bed you gotta go to sleep or else
the monster's gonna get you nightmares
are coming for you
good thing there's a
sign on that door I never know where my
own child was sleeping you still in
there monster check anything in your
closet
maybe good night child you sleep good
don't let anything get you in the middle
of the night yeah don't be under the
covers it's dangerous under there all
right good night child good night
Tommy anyway
hmm he does not belong to this door
interesting
all right what about this one
hmm
I have
ah key I don't like all these closets
does not bode good is this oh cool this
room's on the other side of Tommy's room
anyway I got another key probably one of
these works
hmm
oh well that doesn't make any sense at
all
why would there be a new key
squeaky uh flashlight here oh
food
why is everything in my house locked
doesn't make any sense oh well I don't
know if that was a good idea I think
probably I wanted to keep the outside
locked
something tells me that this is going to
be a bad
Where's Tommy's Window
oh
oh wait that's not Tommy's Window
oh
I don't want to go down there that
zombies wait Tommy doesn't have a window
note to self build Tommy a window so I
can haunt him from that window
for uh
education to Edge build this character
it's gonna build character
that's what it'll do what the hell is
this why did I come down here
I'm gonna blow up Mr Myers well this is
a bunch of uselessness
all right I don't know why I was there
seems to be a lot of gas canisters man
these are some well that's that's fine
that's fine I guess I shouldn't be too
critical of art close this window
what what window
was the window open
why was it open
why is it open why was the window open
I got bullets I got bullets why do I
have bullets
I don't know
door's locked I bet none of my keys
fitted why is that window open Tommy you
still all right up there Tommy it's me
your father mother your mother it's your
mother Tommy calling you from the
downstairs it's calling you from the
downstairs
Tommy it's your mother
voice downstairs
that's not me Tommy that's not me
why Jose window
someone answered me that didn't I have
another key that I didn't use
I feel like it there must
hey
oh it looked it looked open hello child
surprise 10 30 inspection
ah I see you do have a window
good I'm sorry are you trying to sleep
is this bright I'm sorry yeah are you
burying your face down in there so you
don't have to see this does this bother
you does this help you sleep uh this is
what lightning would look like if it was
stormy out all right fine
good night Tommy
I'll turn the lights out
well I guess you get that one on now
leave it on builds character
anyway It's gotta be another key that
was like down in the basement that's the
only reason why I would imagine that I
was able to go
what was that
something there
who's there
it's locked idiot
wait I did not close that door
wait a minute
wait a minute am I supposed to be
worried about something
all right
hey what are you doing you think I left
this door open you get back here you get
back here right now mister oh I've got
bullets oh
well
[Music]
Tommy looks like the power went out of
the house don't worry I'm outside I'm
not in the house anymore you just stay
right there holy should you stay right
there Tommy I'll never come back
whoa
I'm holding my breath
the frick was that oh God Ah that's not
good that's not good oh that's not good
thing it's not uh monitoring my
microphone or else this would be well
this is going to be this might be a
problem
okay
oh boy oh oh oh wait wait wait stop no
no no no no stop I'm holding you're
oh boy well oh this is a problem
no take Tommy oh wait I'm alive oh oh
interesting interesting ah I thought I'd
be dead instantaneously kill Michael
Myer kill him
simple enough
uh
Tommy it's horrible there's a monster in
the house for real this time Tommy Tommy
he's gone oh well this is a problem oh
good oh wait no stop wait stop let me in
and don't keep doing that okay there's
got to be a gun in here right yeah yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh why don't you why
don't you try me [ __ ] good thing it's
dark
wow why am I holding my gun like this
yeah man I wish I could wipe this jelly
off my face is there any uh ammo in here
any more bullets
[Music]
oh I'm bleeding ah
I'm dying
where are you at
where you at
where are you at
oh
bang wow
I ice trust me I see him
oh boy oh
got you [ __ ] got you even with jamming
my eyeball oh oh oh oh oh oh oh wait
wait oh that's a problem okay that's a
problem um
uh I'll hold my breath he definitely
won't see the blood that's the music
I'm fine
is he still there oh that's a problem
well oh he's injured well I'm injured
too ah I'm dead I'm Not Dead I'm dead
probably for the best because I couldn't
see anything
oh
whoa
[Music]
okay so I'm not gonna hold my breath
until he gets all the way down the
stairs because that's when he was like
hey wait a minute oh nothing here weird
[Music]
really weird
weird how there's a whole lot of nothing
up here
down here very straight uh why don't you
go get Tommy
he's upstairs
oh well that's a problem wait
how am I supposed to get inside
he's just standing there
okay he's just standing there he's just
looking oh well all right oh God come on
what is the point of this what's the
point of that you can't even get around
him all right fine whatever I'm just
gonna go get the gun I'm gonna blast his
ass I bet there's a key in here even
though I can't oh again with that [ __ ]
even if I can't see it
I bet there's a key in here it's a big
jam oh wait the gun's not here oh the
gun's over no
gun's not here it's in one of these
closets maybe uh
interesting
well
that kind of throws my plans off a bit I
was gonna blast your ass but uh looks
like oh it's right there well uh
peekaboo
foreign
[Music]
wow
wow okay he's some kind of an idiot
here we go I'm gonna use this
opportunity to get the hell oh God oh
God no no no don't don't do it don't do
it don't do it don't do it don't do it
don't do it yeah that's right that's
right you thought you thought you
thought you thought you thought but
there was no key there so what is the
solution where are the bullets certainly
there would not be bullets in Tommy's
room
but there is some Randomness to this
because the gun was in a slightly
different location oh god oh blood
raining from the ceilings something but
if this isn't the way to go then there's
really nothing and if I'm trying to look
for a tiny key I'm never gonna see it
and I've got Jam in my eyes
can I run by you or are you gonna still
slap me okay so I can run by him
it just depends let me let me bam I
some
I don't think there would be bullets in
Tommy's room but uh you never know I
guess
Tommy are you in there let me expose
your hiding spot oh Tommy
well
all right here we go here we go you
prick I'm gonna blast your ass Wham
reloading and
no no no no that's right you fall down
there's gotta be more stuff that I'm
missing but I'm just not seeing it uh I
I'm not finding any more bullets the no
drawers can be opened none of this can
be opened none of that is anything that
doesn't have any rings there's
definitely no boy
is able to phase through doors
interesting I can't get into the
basement there I don't know where the
last key would be and if it is a key
thing like the keys are so tiny that
there's just no way to see them he's I
know he's crawling up a storm but I'm
just gonna blow best and oh
cause other than this I really don't
think that there's much that I can do
also doors don't seem to do anything to
stop him so I'm not even gonna bother
trying to open a door or close a door on
his face ah the only thing I can think
of is like it's got to be in that room
right it just has to be there's nothing
else here
besides that room 911 please and this is
all just nothing nothing the thing
didn't have any more bullets I only got
two bullets here so really like what can
I do
nothing and then nothing shut up
oh and then oh no I'm going oh well
frick
he doesn't know a thing
he's completely forgotten me man I'm I'm
stumped you know I I've I've stumped I
can figure out how to get around him no
I can't but I can't I can't figure out
how to progress at all I can't see where
the key is because all the lights are
locked
in all honesty am I expected to just
hunt around every scrap of floor to be
able to find it I checked Tommy's room
because I thought there might be
something there I checked that other
room again I took down to the basement
again I checked around the other area
really not a whole lot of nothing you
know what I mean really kind of just a
bunch of empathyness I'm running around
oh god let's see if I can escape by him
I probably can oh
okay while I slowed down there for some
reason I just decided to stop running
you know how it'd be now I've got that
jam on my face but again wait
that was not there that was not there
before
did I have to run out of bullets before
it would give me more bullets
[Music]
wow
wow that can't oh he's gone
no he's not
really wow you guys didn't see nearly as
much as I was wandering around there I
was so confused that was it that was I
was looking for a key I was looking for
a key that was an unopened door child
what is wrong with you you're hiding all
the bullets child child I never a child
how could you
wish I could see anything it's awfully
dark oh about time you showed up this
child's haircut is a crime arrest this
child will you with your jump suit is
that a race track jumpsuit you nerd you
nerd anyway
pretty good uh I struggled a lot with
them
I can't say it was bad it was just like
uh it wasn't clear what I was supposed
to do or how to get bullets I apparently
had to use up all my bullets before it
would give me more
oh well wait a minute uh sorry I'm
supposed to be like my camera's not
working at the moment
um just hold on uh I'll be with you in a
moment I'm gonna like yeah I'll try to
figure out like something there's got to
be something wrong with the wires or
something just uh hold tight I gotta get
this job I don't know why the camera's
working fine
everything's plugged in uh let's see
um
that's weird so I'm plugged in here that
I've never seen before
uh I don't know if I should unplug it
but it doesn't look like it belongs here
I'll I'll unplug it I guess all right
maybe this will fix it three two one
here we go
[Music]